thing as a high value woman
if so what does that look like start
here go around
I think there is a high value woman
because
[Music]
um
I like I know that men care about
women's past and women care about a
man's future so
I think men do
look for a high value woman
so what traits does does she have
so she's like what a virgin you just
said that they care about in their past
like what what is well like I can't
really answer that because I feel like
every man has its own okay you don't
think there's any general things it's
just you don't know
um maybe like body count I feel like
some guys care about body count and
what women do for a living and their
mindsets and their goals in life
what do you think
uh I think there is high value women I
think
they have to have some traits like you
have to be motivated after motivating me
in some way that also have to be family
orientated because I'm big on family so
that's definitely high value and I will
say
I don't know because some people has
passed and they have history you know
but you can't really judge them from
that so I don't know if that you can't
judge for on their past yeah it's like
can I judge a man if he has a past of
like prison
uh
you can but that person can't change
though so oh I shouldn't
you want your dog like your daughter
your sister going out with a guy
a prison but me personally if I meet the
guy and I like him oh wow in some ways I
think that's bad advice
for guys your daughter prison pass
you're cool with anyone listen if the
dude was in prison for molesting a kid
and you're like but I like him you might
want to rethink well obviously that's
like specific you know I mean like if he
was just in prison about anything else
then I'd probably give him a chance but
like in general I don't really hold
people from what they've done okay it's
who they are now okay so for high value
women to you body count doesn't matter
if it's a thousand you're cool
I wouldn't say I'm cool okay okay
so yeah okay okay so what how how many
bodies she got to be under I'll say
probably
stay on the bike
20. okay under 20. she's high value yeah
okay what else and I'll say definitely
need to motivate me in some way I'll say
because I'm a gym person I'll say she's
health healthy okay yeah and
um
high value
who's is there a woman you think of when
you think of a high value woman
someone in the media if not it's okay
but I'm just wondering I'm really
working my brain I'm just gonna yeah
yeah
um
not right now I wouldn't like choose a
specific one right now okay yeah what do
you think I think with higher value
women it could mean different things I
think if a woman's got respect she's
kind she's honest she's got like a
business mentality and she's hard
working that to me so she's a higher
value because she's putting in that
extra effort and a lot I know a lot of
girls that sit around at home all day
don't do nothing with their life but
then you see a lot of women that work
their asses off you know and to me that
shows that they're trying to be good
women you know I don't think no no
I don't even really care no yeah it's
like it's like nothing to them okay okay
it's like it's like you know I have a
guy who talks about a shoe collection
yeah and yoga that's nice but I don't
care oh yeah okay yeah okay it's like
our jobs you know yeah I think I think
it's hard because everyone's got like a
different Vision in their head of how a
woman should be I'm just curious so okay
so you said she's gotta have respect
like what what what does she have to do
to be a high value woman like what
skills does she have to have
what what does she have to look like
well we all know a man likes a classy
woman right not all men but we all know
a man likes to cry to him not someone
that shows there are stuff on Instagram
or you know oh sorry does that sort of
thing so in my head a higher value woman
to a man is someone that dresses
appropriately okay and has more rules
okay whatever that means to some people
okay but um the bar is low that's it I
mean
so don't sleep all right this is what I
got so far don't sleep with 20 people
don't have your butt on Instagram
shape
and be respectable yeah that's it okay
I'm just repeating that I feel like
it'll come back to me that's okay okay
what do you think what is a high value
woman it doesn't exist because some
people don't believe in it so it's up to
you it has to exist
but it's completely different to what
makes a high value man I think women
judge a high value Man based on the
things that we want and what we look for
so
um a high value woman has to be based on
what men are looking for which is going
to be completely different so it would
be younger women uh top 20 to 20.
in shape yeah not not got everything out
on Instagram and low body count once
kids wants family wants a husband
doesn't want to go out on uh girls
holidays
um all those kinds of things
to Beast okay what do you think no I
don't believe there's high value women I
believe value is contextual okay so it's
all very dependent on what you see at
the end of the day you could have a
woman who is what Society theme is
overweight and a man might value that
really highly because that's what he
wants it all depends on somebody's
experience so I don't believe there's
high value women I believe that there
are women who want to put out certain
ways about them and if that's what they
want to do then that's awesome and there
are women who are going to do what
they're going to do and men will still
idolize and worship them anyway that's
what I believe anyway
sorry can you explain that again so yeah
so value is contextual right so it
depends on how
someone will perceive that woman so
somebody might look at I don't know the
queen and see she's high value because
she's head of the monarchy and she owns
Windsor Castle and all the rest of it
some of us look at the queen of things I
can't stand it I don't like her at all
she's not high value to me okay whereas
somebody may look at somebody that lives
within a council estate and
they may aspire to be with a woman like
that but you don't think there's you
don't think there's like General things
that most men like most men might look
at
I don't know Margot Robbie Beyonce 20
years ago and say like the high value or
good looking like you don't think
there's General things that like men
want good looking doesn't mean high
value though somebody can there's loads
of people are good looking it doesn't
mean that they're high value so at the
end of the day I'm just wondering if it
starts there at least for guys no so I
can only talk for myself but for me
personally looks doesn't necessarily
then equate to high value I've seen
women that are what people classifies
tens and their values are -10 so at the
end of the day to me it's contextual
very very content well I'm not saying
I'm not saying it's just like I'm saying
it's not looks alone but like you that
would start there like I don't think you
can be like 300 pounds and be high value
as a girl I just think it doesn't it
depends on who's looking I know men that
want 300 pound girls and they deem them
to be high value so it just depends in
my opinion I think usually those guys
can't get laid by anyone else very true
because I don't see you know I just I
don't see the rich man like bringing the
whales to functions you know very very
true but then we're not looking here
from a momentum point of view we're
looking from a women's point of view the
question you asked was is what do people
deem to be a high value so I'm not
looking as a high value man looking as a
high value woman I'm just looking at
what a high value woman is you know I
was looking I was thinking of it from
the men's point of view because I'm just
looking at like the most sought after
men tend to pick which isn't like fat
chicks okay so if we're looking at you
from that way the most sought after men
no they wouldn't necessarily picked that
although some men have some really crazy
fetishes so they may say that they don't
want these women on the surface but then
what they're doing behind closed doors
is they've I mean every King had
concubines but it doesn't make her Queen
you know no doesn't at all but he might
deem that woman so the high value woman
might be the one that he puts on a
pedestal but then he might be the woman
that he's sleeping with that's 300
pounds high value as well because she's
given him what he needs at the time that
he needs it so it's all very contagious
yeah but I would think you'd have like
results to show you know what I mean
like you'd have like a ring or like a
house some concubines have
rings they might but I just I don't
really see them bringing the concubines
out in public like they're usually in
the back you know I agree with that I
agree with you don't yeah they don't
bring those concubines but those
concubines get to live in the Ivory
Tower yeah and they're quite happy with
it as well so yeah to me it's contextual
okay what do you think do high value
women exist yeah yeah have I ever even
how value women does exist
um because uh like uh
yeah
the first time being on the set so they
gave it after you know so what was the
question again all right so what is a
high value do high-value women exist and
what is a high value woman so a high
value woman is like a girl that got
herself put together like uh that go out
there every single day to work
um on what they love
and also like does it party all the time
and um
yeah that's what I got so is Oprah a
high value woman
Oprah high value no uh yeah but no at
the same time okay but I think yeah I
forget I forget and just some of you
guys the bar is like low wow I don't
really yeah everything it's like with
this everyone here is a high value
like I think it depends though like
because it's like there's women out
there that works to separate himself
from the rest which is why I can
appreciate that you know I mean but
obviously
we all like humans we like what we like
but I believe like there is High Valley
women out there there is women that
really go out there and gets it they're
really put in the work to be taller yeah
yeah
um I guess like what you guys most of
you not you but are describing it's just
like it's very like a low bar like we
don't really got to do much you might be
right I'm I'm just asking the question
what do you think is there a high value
woman or do high-value women exist if so
who are they well so this is an
interesting question I pondered about
this a little bit too because there's a
lot of people that'll ask like oh you
know high value men so that's that's the
other side of it is the does the high
value Man exist right people like what's
a high value man well that's an easy
question to answer it's just a high
value man first of all who measures
value like we have to have an objective
standard we can't be delusional and be
like everybody likes different things
well if you know if this grows into this
King then she's a high value woman it's
like is she high value because you're
into crapping in her mouth and she takes
it that makes her high value that's
absolutely crazy a kink doesn't make a
person high value makes them a sexual
object I can buy a sexual object and if
I can buy it it's not going to be a lot
of value in the marketplace because
there's a lot of dudes that can buy it
so who determines value that's an
interesting question and the answer is
it's the market that determines the
value like for people don't know what
that means it's like buy my house for a
billion dollars it's like but this house
sucks yeah but I determine my own value
it's a billion dollars how many people
buy that house
zero people who determines the value of
a house the market what does that mean
it's the Willing number of buyers that
are going to pay the maximum price and
the highest bidder usually wins so the
value has to be determined by the
highest bidder that's how things work in
life right so a high value woman would
be a woman that is sought after by the
highest bidder the highest bidding net
now this is a really interesting
question because this is a actually a
really interesting discussion with a
friend of mine about this like what does
it mean to bet on a woman see this is
where women get confused right because
women are like oh a lot of guys want to
sleep with me and they DM me so I'm a
high value woman
but that's but that's a misnomer in the
in the value Marketplace and there's a
really easy answer for that right like
here's a question for you guys how many
people in the world today can go pay
cash and buy a Ferrari is that a lot or
a little hello it's a little how many
people can save up for a little bit and
uh rent a Ferrari for their wedding or
their graduation
quite a lot of people right so women are
like oh these dudes are hitting me I'm
High Valley it's like no you're a rental
car
a lot of guys can save up and rent a
nice car for a day you're not high value
so high value cannot be a rental car a
car value a high value has to be an
owner car so a high value Woman by the
definition of the market is just what is
the highest status or the highest value
or most desired because that's how men's
values marketed you know what is the
highest value man that is willing to
give you what
ring a ring there it is it's the highest
value man that's willing to give you a
ring so if you can get dudes that want
to hump you but they don't want to give
you a ring you're not high value and
that's that's the answer the high value
women exists yes because I'm married for
for 10 years with four kids
uh and I know a lot of other dudes that
are doing pretty darn well uh that are
married to these women
but then it goes back to what I was
saying before so it's contextual
so
it's like I could say my mum's high
value but my mum's done a lot of stuff
that other people would have deemed to
be high value but my mom's high value
but she's worth something to me she's my
mum she raised me yes but we're talking
about sexual market value we're not
talking about do I love my mother it's a
totally different argument I get I get
that but where I come back is that what
you're saying is basically why I put in
a nutshell's contextual so you can be
married so it's what you're saying is
that basically it's a woman who a man's
worth willing to put a ring on yeah a
man might be waiting to put a ring on
somebody that's 300 pounds so in no man
listen listen
I know guys and I'm gonna bring him to
Pearl show on Saturday by the way if you
guys are going to watch I hope it's
going to be amazing I know guys worth
100 million dollars like I was with one
just the other day at my place and Henry
was filming I was having a conversation
it's like no dude is like I've made a
hundred million dollars now it's time to
bag me a 300 pounder and my and my life
is complete zero men not even one man is
thinking that you know I think then
again it's contextual because I can go
to my account I go to my place of
Heritage where I know a man who is
incredibly rich and his woman is over
250 pounds and that's his wife yeah and
he parades her everywhere and he's very
happy to do it and the concubines
Parade's probably the right word here
and the concubines that he has are women
who other men would be high value how
long have they been together 15 years
okay yeah but was she like that one he
like was was he Rich then he was rich
and he picked a fat and he's always
speak to women that are larger because
that's his thing so again it's
contextual but that's not market value
it's like yeah some some guys like you
know a shitty car that breaks down
because they're into this vintage shitty
car but that's not that's not the market
value that's just the guy right you're
applying group statistics to an
individual which is fine and I agree
with your argument you're like well my
mom is high value because she does a lot
of good things for me you know my kid
her kids Society Etc I get that
obviously in the context of the show
we're talking about sexual market value
right now if a guy likes a if a guy
likes a whale let me say this that's a
terrible strategy for a woman to implore
in her life like well some guys like me
if I'm 300 pounds it's like
yeah but that's not maximizing for
Success yeah that's true that's you're
at that point you're just a disabled
parking spot right like guys will park
with you but they'll check if anyone's
looking first
that's the point would you if you had do
you have kids yeah we've got daughter
yeah if you were going to give her
advice
just generally because if you've got a
son you tend to give your kids advice on
how to grow up and be a good man how
if you were to advise your daughter your
recommendation wouldn't probably be to
yeah just get as fat as you like because
some man out there will love you you
kind of
you want your child to kind of aim
you know yeah do you know what I think I
think of getting a good man I know my
viewpoints are very different to most
people so like we could look at things
holistically like of course we can we
can look at things holistically look at
it and at the end of the day right and
we have to on a show yeah because
they're going to show it's not about
individuals like we're talking about
Society in general
um what do you think high value woman I
definitely exist yeah and from like
listening to everybody I like I'd list
uh looks body count probably important
uh for me intelligence definitely high
up there
uh loyalty is a big deal and nurturing
for sure if I would list it as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and to monetize on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible